je voudrais vous poser des questions si
vous voulez répondre oui vous avez juste
à main levée d'accord c'est pour vous
tous
alors qu'il a déjà rencontré l'amour au
travail dit avec michel michel ferret
bah oui oui oui c'est quand même là
qu'on se rend compte à la plupart du
temps où était et toi tu as rencontré
beaucoup quelqu'un je peux beaucoup de
mecs outre vraiment les tournages les
tournées bon ben voilà on son école
comme zara bah voilà
ah ouais là moment d'y aller ouais là la
plupart du temps c'est au travail quoi
oui souvent
les tournages l'été comme israël
beaucoup boumelha nîmes le papa de mon
fils
oui au travail le papa par mois le papa
de mon fils aux injecteurs de télévision
et j'étais animatrice est vrai et c'est
sûr il ya les photos vous l'avez fait au
travail non ah ouais ben haim est ce que
vous avez déjà fait au travail non quoi
le travail c'est le travail
ah oui bah ça soit il connaît comment
vous rencontré votre cerveau traite
mario travail ouais bah oui non mais
c'est pas ça n'empêche pas l'élan
amoureux narbonne pour le rsa jamais
fait papa maman travaille abat-jour le
c'est sûr c'est vraiment dommage
bah oui le ciel est noir sur montceau
les mines
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors donc l'état manchots les mines ou
alors qu'il s'est passé nous sommes au
début des années 2000 une époque où je
suis célibataire ça m'arrive pas souvent
et donc j'avoue j'en profite
généralement que vous êtes célibataire
c'est vrai que c'est le miel et les
abeilles les neuf secondes le bout quoi
sur un ça va c'est la folie quoi sera
bien sûr c'est nous c'est un bandeau
gilbert des célibataires actuellement tu
allais à montceau-les-mines peut
rencontrer dans le cadre de l'écriture
d'un livre sur la g auxerre qui ne se
fera pas finalement rencontré un témoin
et donc j'arrive place de la gare à
montceau-les-mines y pleut j'attends une
heure mon témoin ne vient pas je ne sais
pas quoi faire et je vous jure j'ai un
petit succès quand même et on verra
alors si l'envié vous vient à bout à
mieux
là là ça y est accomplie date on
comprend mieux mais il faut savoir vous
le savez pas vous mais sur montceau les
mines wii sony mines ya pas une plaque à
vent sur une plaque d'égout à son goût
alors oui et donc il pleut personne ne
vient décide de rentrer dans un café et
là je vous jure
une brune sophistiqués je m'en souviens
encore magnifique vraiment entreprend
vraiment montreux proposez vous aux bois
mon cabas elle commence à me dire voilà
je vous trouve bien qu est ce que vous
venez faire jura compte un peu ces
procès sont des dons et donc elle
commence à me dire mais franchement j'ai
un rêve
emmenez moi à paris non non et là moi ça
mais en fait j'aimerais juste un moyen
de transport c'est vrai que la mer c'est
plus rare c'est rare qu'à parler au
tournant mais le moins bon sur les
lignes elle voulait voir ça tu aurais
fait oui
dix artistes
sorti en nicolas certis hockey
[Musique]
allah
et donc elle me dit oui mais moi j'avais
pas de voiture j'étais venu en train lui
dit pas de problème vous prend tout de
suite un billet pour paris par le
prochain train et la fa casser
complètement le truc pourquoi m'at elle
voulait que j'emmène en voiture sans
douleur et mais pas le train ne sais pas
premièrement je me posais en première
mais du coup ça m'a cassé complètement
sortis seuls du café c'est c'est la fin
de l'histoire
oui elle est triste mais c'est bien ça
commençait bien mais bon c'est vrai et
et personnes non mais je vous dit vous
n'êtes pas obligés parce que vous avez
déjà trouvé l'amour c'est à dire vous
c'est peut-être que soit l'appareil on
vous je vous connais vous aimez bien
aimé mais chez platonique optex devez
non mais c'est vrai alors moi c'était
sur un livre que j'ai raison j'ai vu
chauzy non mais c'était quand j'écrivais
mon livre sur françois fillon oui j'ai
rencontré une personnalité et on est
tombé amoureux voilà ça a un peu de
temps mais on est resté ensemble non ah
ben non mais je rêve sera libre non
monsieur en écrivant à lille pétanque
est tu sais tu te déplaces sur le tas on
s'était pas françois fillon il est écrit
version il était divorcé il avait deux
filles n'ont pas trouvé non non quand
vous parlez de rencontrer l'amour faut
que ce soit réciproque ou constat marche
c'est beau non sa part sur la marche pas
vous lasser mathieu de longs mois parce
que moi pour le coup j'ai rencontré
l'amour c'est la première fois que ça
m'arrive au travail parce que d'habitude
je me met des barrières et là ça m'est
tombé dessus comme un meuble là c'est
lui qui met des barrières mais je ne
perds pas espoir
alors vous a gagné a marqué juste week
end au téléphone il est ce c'est en
train de faire son chemin
ouais on a promis quoi on irait mange
ensemble cette semaine et peut-être moi
il m'a promis que ce serait moi qui
périt
les balades non vraiment c'est que ça
devrait se faire
[Applaudissements]